>>Nic Francis: I think we're going. We going.
He's says we're definitely going.
Um, so do I think the economy is going to
recover? Probably not in 2009. But in terms
of whether it will slow down ____ or not,
I think it will. But maybe it won't. Maybe
what it will do is insure that we make very
good decisions because there's less finance.
One of the things that we are fixated on is
things like encapture, sorry, carbon capture
and storage or how do we make coal clean.
We think about and talk about nuclear power
stations, we talk about renewables. But actually
if we don't meet our goals on climate 50%dwill
come from energy efficienty. It's the cheapest
thing to do, it's the quickest thing to do
and we can do it right now. So, therefore,
with a shortage of captial it makes more sense.
So maybe we might act quicker. So maybe it's
a good thing.
Bye. This is how I turn it off. No this one.
He's telling me again.